all right you
genderless anime avatars it is october
20th 2020 that's right it's 10 20 20 20.
there's some symmetry for you
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
and uh it's morning here but i have had
a day and a half already i was up at 3
45 a.m this morning for a 4 15
a.m hit on fox and friends uh talked a
little bit
about what's going on with censorship
related to twitter and facebook and all
that stuff and then they
caught wind of a video that we did post
here hopefully you've seen it already
i did a periscope the other day from uh
the trump rally in beverly hills
and it was just it was just wild if you
haven't seen it please check it out i
mean it was
just as i say in the video it's just the
reverse of everything they tell you a
trump rally is all about there were
blacks and whites and gays and straights
and asians and latinos oh my
everybody was there everybody was having
fun it was
it almost felt like it actually felt
like like a breath of fresh air or sort
of like an
exhale really of just like there's such
anger out there such craziness and again
it feels
probably worse than it is because of
social media uh but just to be around a
bunch of happy people
just yelling and screaming and honking
horns and the fact that it was in
freaking
beverly hills of all places i mean it
was basically right on the corner if you
know la at all
of santa monica and rodeo drive rodeo
drive
is the famous strip where all the fancy
stores are all the italian names that i
won't even pretend to pronounce are all
there like the elite of the elite
of hollywood and you know all the all
the money
people in this town that that's where
they spend all day long
and to to just be around people who just
think a little bit differently
and it was just it was just great i was
i was mobbed by people and it was just
great
meeting everybody and everything else
and apparently they do this they do this
every saturday and they're going to do
it through the election so if you're
if you're in la or in in the socal area
uh
it's uh in beverly hills on saturdays
around three o'clock
uh but anyway so i was up early this
morning for fox and friends
and uh you know downed some coffee
smacked myself in the face a couple of
times
and managed to put a couple sentences
together and then
this trump guy that everyone's always
talking about he was on a few minutes
after me
and he actually mentioned that he
watched he said oh i watched that
that portion with dave rubin and he made
a good point something something to that
effect
so i got a shout out from the president
which is nice and i'm sure my haters
will use that
as fuel to try to destroy me but don't
worry guys i'm
i'm gonna be okay i have a guard dog
everything's gonna be just fine
uh all right so what we're gonna do
today is three stories
sort of loosely around the election but
not all quite around the election
a little video game stuff in there too
first i want to start with this story
about andrew cuomo he is the mayor
sorry he is the governor of new york and
as most of you guys know i
i lived in new york most of my life i
lived there from 1976 to 2013
until i moved to california how it is
that i've only lived in new york and
california and became sane is
probably should be studied by
sociologists in years to come
but he is now saying that he'll be
skeptical of any covid vaccine
that the cdc or the fda released and
really what he's linking that to is
because that will have something to do
with trump
and it's like these are the trust the
scientist guys and it's like oh i guess
we're only supposed to trust the
scientists when it's your scientists or
something like that
so we're gonna play a little video of
that we'll we'll unpack that as they say
uh then i wanna bust out two tweets for
you to show you how
the never trumpers sort of the
conservative never trumpers
on the right i guess they say they're on
the right and the progressives
uh the bernie progressives the biden
progressives whatever the hell that
thing is at this point
how they actually need trump because i
got two tweets from robert reich who's
clinton's former
uh what was he former labor secretary
and david frum who's a former george w
bush speechwriter and they're pretty
twisted in some of the messaging that
they're putting out there and they seem
to want trials for those of us that
don't believe
the same things that they believe so
we're going to talk about that and then
playstation people as some of you know i
was once
a an assistant manager at electronics
boutique in
uh long island i moved more pokemon red
than anybody back in 99.
well playstation has now put out a black
lives matter
theme so that you can get a dose of
marxism
as you're playing crash bandicoot it's
all very very exciting
all right guys before we get to all of
that
are you looking for a new protein bar i
have a feeling that you are
are you looking for one that tastes like
a candy bar well i've got just the brand
for you guys
built bars are super tasty and come in
18
amazing flavors i've pimped out the
peanut butter we've talked about the
chocolate
i like the cookies and cream although
the peanut butter is pretty spectacular
too
and there's 15 other flavors right there
they're covered in 100
chocolate including both nut and nut
free flavors and are soft and easy to
chew you know a lot of these protein
bars
kind of gritty and like kind of
chemically these are not guys
and with halloween just around the
corner it's easy to slip up which is why
bill bars are the perfect alternative to
candy for the health conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
bill bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein and high fiber
guys go to biltbar.com and use promo
code ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off your first your first order at
billbar.com good for bars built go
or bill boost and now back to me hello
all right let's talk about uh new york
governor andrew cuomo uh he has he has
botched
well you know this is one of those
things when i say that there's a reality
war out there
and just depending on what news you
listen to you you view the world in one
very specific way and often that's
completely counter to how someone else
views it
i think this is a good example because
in the world that i
see from the sources that i read and i
try to keep them varied
andrew cuomo has really botched the
covid response we know that he
sent all sorts of elderly people back
into nursing homes where they died he's
sort of denying it now even though he
had
admitted it before and then he goes on
cnn and his brother basically says
you know he's jesus too for how great he
did with kovid
um you know new york is still in various
parts of lockdowns even now they're
starting lockdowns again
in parts of brooklyn and i'm assuming
some other places as well
but some people seem to think that he's
the hero of the corona thing and there's
a rumor out there now
that he could be attorney general in a
harris
biden administration and yes i call it a
harris biden administration
anyway putting all of that aside whether
you think he did well or he did
horribly or somewhere in between you
know now we've got all this talk about a
coveted vaccine happening and the left
always tells us
to trust the science science is science
believe all scientists you know
scientists lives matter
that's what they tell us but apparently
cuomo doesn't
fully believe that because i guess in
this case the scientists are
trump scientists from the cdc and the
fda let's take a look
i do want to ask you about that
especially as it pertains to the vaccine
we saw dr fauci last night say that he
trusts the experts
at the fbi at the fda how confident are
you
in the approval process of the fda right
now
well first uh how confident am i
uh i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people
are that confident you're going to say
to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly
but trust this federal administration
and their health
administration that it's safe uh
and um we're not 100 sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be
so what's it going to take to convince
you that it's safe that it's effective
that it should be distributed
well what i said i'm going to do in new
york is we're going to put together our
own group of doctors and medical experts
to review
the vaccine and the efficacy in the
protocol
and if they say it's safe then i'll go
to the people of new york and i
will say it safe uh with that
credibility but i believe all across the
country
you're going to need someone other than
this fda and this cdc
saying it's safe and that means we're
going to need a change in the white
house is that what you're saying
no i look i i personally hope for a
change in the white house but put that
aside
if this administration continued the cdc
george and the fda doesn't have any
credibility you have dr fauci now
saying that they basically tried to
muzzle him he has the highest
credibility in the nation
on this issue and then
not only is the vaccine safe this
administration is learning
nothing from the past ah
well you got it there at the end what
this is really all about which of course
it's all about a change in the white
house now
there's a few things to talk about there
first off i'll i'll give
cuomo credit where credit is due which
is that you should be skeptical just
because the government says something
whatever that thing might be
doesn't mean you automatically should
believe it whether whether it's about
the economy or foreign policy
or about health care or a vaccine or
whatever it is just because some
government person says this is what we
should do
and this works doesn't mean you
automatically should believe it you
should think about it you should
talk to experts you should listen to
experts i mean we've got a plethora
now have you guys heard about these
podcasts they're everywhere and
you can hopefully ascertain a little
information from yourself this is
something we could not do as easily
even 10 years ago it would have been
much harder to do so just because
the government says something doesn't
mean it's automatically true or right
and that doesn't mean
and that includes whether it's a
republican administration or a
democratic
democrat administration or anything else
so in the in the skeptical part he's
right
but what he's doing before that is
basically
undermining the fda and the cdc because
it's not his guy meaning it's not a
democrat
that's the president right now and as he
said at the end he personally wants
trump to be out of office so if we're
going to say trust the scientists
which is a silly notion right you know
there's a lot of evil scientists out
there there's a lot of bad guy
scientists out there have you ever seen
a science fiction movie i mean
not every scientist is right about
everything and by the way you know what
happens in science you're not going to
believe this guys
there are often discoveries that then
get debunked
by things after that as we get finer
instruments and more information and the
rest of it science is often in the
business of debunking
science that's that's the beautiful
thing you know um
so when he says this thing about well he
won't trust the fda then he said
something interesting then he said well
if we get
the vaccine from the fda that he then
would get his scientists in new york
they would get a panel because this is
what governments do we're going to get a
panel we're going to study it blah blah
but that doesn't really make sense
because if if you don't trust the trump
scientists because they're
trump scientists let's say it's a poor
way to put it actually but in essence
that's what he's saying we don't trust
the trump scientists
well then why should people on the right
why should conservatives
believe the democratic scientists and
now this is what politicizing
science looks like it's deeply dangerous
we're not going to trust your science
scientists we're going to trust our
scientists and by the way this idea
of that the states should study it as
well this is something that gavin newsom
wants to do here in california as well
now i'll just be very clear about one
other thing i'm not against the states
deciding what they want to do how they
want to administer it
whether they want to administer it at
all i mean you know my feelings on this
i want things to be as local
as possible but the reason i thought
this was an important story
it speak is because you look if it was
their guy in the white house they would
say we want a national
mandate that everyone's going to have to
take it but it because it isn't
now we're going to undermine the very
institutions that you all say constantly
that
trump is is undermining right so if
trump comes out against the cdc they'll
tell you how great the cdc is if trump
comes out against the fda they'll tell
you how wonderful the fda is
now if trump does something in
conjunction with them
now we don't trust them but we also say
trust the scientists
i think i've made my point here so be
wary people
not just of the scientists but be wary
of the politicians who were in this just
to maintain and continue their power
grab that that's what i'm worried about
far more than i'm worried about
the scientists um okay so moving on i
wanted to
show you two tweets because i've been
thinking about a theory
lately and i've been teasing it here a
little bit sort of this idea
that what i would say now are sort of
powerful fringe groups actually
need trump groups that hate trump what
what
unifies them actually what gives them
their power
is trump and by these two groups what
i'm talking about
are the far left progressives which are
now the base of the democratic party
the bernie bros the marxist the blm guys
the whole thing
and i'm also talking about the never
trump conservatives now it's hard to
tell how many never trump conservatives
are they've got a ton
of money and there's this lincoln
project and they've got all of this
non-profit money and
it's very clear they buy influence
through think tanks and they buy social
media
views and and all of that stuff because
you never hear somebody really talking
about them with any degree of
passion or anything else they're they're
definitely doing something
related to social media and all that and
we know obviously people you can buy
followers you can buy influence and and
all of that stuff uh
but i found these two tweets one by
robert reich who is the former labor
secretary for bill clinton who's now a
bernie supporter and a big progressive
economist okay so this is firmly a lefty
and then david frum who was a former
speechwriter
for george w bush he's the one that
actually
wrote the line in george bush's famous
speech that got us into the iraq war
the axis of evil talking about iran iraq
and north korea he was the one
originally
if i'm not mistaken it was going to be
called the axis of hatred
but they changed it to axis of evil i
guess that does sound a little better
for a bumper sticker
but this guy obviously worked for george
w bush he's a he's a neocon
basically has gotten everything wrong
pretty much forever
but clearly is a conservative right well
well i can't say clearly he's a
conservative
has been on the right politically and is
a never trumper
you know from the right let's say so
you've got this lefty and this righty
and they both put out
interesting tweets so we're going to
pull up the tweets and i want to dissect
them because they're both up to an
extremely dangerous game
and i've seen this game being played by
by many more people the i'm not just
singling these guys out
many more people from this line of
thinking are tweeting similar things
so let's go to the robert reich tweet
first and this is what he said this is
just two or three days ago
he said when this nightmare is over we
need a truth and reconciliation
commission
it would erase trump's lies comfort
those who have been harmed
by his hatefulness and name every
official politician executive
and media mogul whose greed and
cowardice
enabled this catastrophe i mean
i know that using nazi analogies
is a bit cliche these days but that
actually sounds like some nazi stuff
like we're gonna
find the co-conspiracies we're gonna
name them and not just the government
ones the private citizen ones
and then we'll figure out what to do
with them i actually retweeted him
and i changed a word or two so the way i
worded it was
when this lefty nightmare is over so go
with me on this guys right
because this just shows you how silly it
all sounds imagine if i had tweeted out
something like this you know how
frustrated i am with the left
you know what i i view the the dangerous
ideas of leftism have become
but imagine i tweeted out this statement
when this
lefty nightmare is over we need a truth
and reconciliation commission
it would erase their lies comfort those
who have been harmed by their
hatefulness
and name every official politician
executive and media mogul whose greed
and cowardice
enabled their catastrophe well that
actually makes a hell of a lot more
sense to me because they're destroying
everything
that once was this great country uh but
i'm not looking
to name people and and grab people and
figure out what to do with people you
can see the twisted way this goes
in the name of oh we must put this thing
behind us we're gonna have to put a lot
of people in cages we're gonna have to
ruin a lot of lives so that's coming
from the left that's robert reich and
then
this gem a day or two ago from david
frum
the people on the far right and the far
left
who publicized the obviously bogus
new york post story were not dupes
they were accomplices the story
could not have been more obviously fake
it if it had been
wearing a dollar store spectacles and
attached
plastic mustache now putting aside his
poor imagery there
uh there's a couple tricks he does there
first off if you don't agree with him
you're
far right or you're far left right and
you're the ones pushing the
obviously bogus story now what he's
talking about of course is this hunter
biden story
uh that about the laptop and the emails
that basically show
that joe biden was involved in some
level of shenanigans
in in the ukraine right uh and we know
that hunter got the job with no
uh with no qualifications or anything
else like that and we know he was making
a ton of money and everything else but
putting that whole
issue aside no one from the biden
campaign has denied it
not only is no one denied it biden is
now in hiding he literally put a lid
on the campaign yesterday and he's not
coming out till thursday that means he
has no public appearances for the next
couple days if we had a responsible
media which we don't
they might be saying hey biden you can't
just hide when a story is coming out
against you
but what i think is most interesting is
not far right
and not far left and not obviously
fake obviously bogus they were
accomplices
and that sounds very much like the other
language of a truth and reconciliation
commission
and what they're signaling to you as a
free thinking person
their signaling to you is we will try to
come for you too once we take out trump
you better be afraid of us
because people like this want to use
state power
to silence those who they disagree with
now you can say all the things you want
about trump right
you can say them all and how many people
how many political opponents
has he jailed how many lists has he come
up with
how many accomplices has he found and
the answer really is none
the fbi is doing some work now to find
out if there was some collusion
with the obama administration about
taking trump out
but this this idea that we're going to
use the state to take out our political
opponents
the accomplices and we're going to have
lists and everyone else is far right and
far left
man this is dangerous stuff and when
people talk about
the political horseshoe theory that the
far left and the far right
they become one thing what they usually
mean by that is that collectivists
whether you're far left or far right
usually become the same thing so if
you're a collectivist on the left
you believe that skin color matters you
believe the gender matters that that is
the supreme stuff that matters and
that's the collectivism you believe in
and ironically that then becomes the
same thing as the people on the far
right say the white supremacists
so often i said this before those guys
really should be on the far left because
they're in many ways
what's what's different right now about
a black lives matter
believer who believes in all of this
race stuff versus white supremacists
they're into the different color of skin
but but that pretty much brings them
together and that's sort of the
horseshoe theory
and i think when you see a progressive
clinton guy and a conservative
bush guy come together that they're
going to come get the rest of us
after this thing i think it is something
to watch out
for that's why i thought the story was
worthy and of note
and finally one more as long as we're
talking about black lives matter uh you
guys know
i'm i'm a big video game guy
unfortunately i don't have much time for
video games these days i can
maybe maybe maybe maybe get like 15
minutes a week and often it's not even
that
but when i do play i usually play uh nba
2k
with my with my 11 year old nephew
in new york and he usually beats me
senseless it's pretty pathetic actually
um but occasionally i'll bust out my old
nes
and play some super mario brothers or
some contra or something like that
and uh i i don't play the games because
i just don't have the time and also as
i've said many times
i like running that way right mario ram
that way i like that and i can jump over
things you know smack a turtle
push it into another guy that sounds
good to me when i gotta
run this way causes all sorts of
problems i'm old what can i tell you
uh anyway playstation which is the
i playstation 4 they just announced
playstation 5 but it's a very popular
video game system amongst the young
people
um they are now allowing you let's let's
pull it up
they are allowing you to show your
support for the hashtag black lives
matter movement
with this new ps4 theme out now
for free at the ps store
now this is this is interesting at many
levels on the simple level you guys know
my feelings about politics
infecting everything you turn on a
basketball game
black lives matter on the court now
you're going to turn on your fake
basketball game on playstation
and you can have a black lives matter
uh theme so with the theme by the way
for those of you that aren't video game
people
the theme is sort of your backdrop to
your whole desktop when you're in
playstation so you can constantly be
looking at the fist
and be thinking about racism uh while
you're playing
i said crash bandicoot before i need
another reference there what are the
kids playing you're playing uh
the grand theft auto that's that's still
out there right
um grand theft auto was probably the
last like
you know current type game i played you
could just walk up to a car
grab someone punch him in the face and
steal their car it was amazing it really
was great
um in any event the idea
that now sports taken over by politics
and
what happened to the nba horrific
ratings video games that you should
the things that are designed for escape
but not only designed for escape they're
designed for
for young people the obviously
playstation video games they skew
young right now we should have i'm not
saying
young people shouldn't be educated about
racism i'm not sure
i'm not saying that young people
shouldn't talk about what is politically
relevant or current events or anything
else like that
but the idea that it would be the
backdrop of all
of whatever they're doing on their
playstation system and of course what
what the real issue here is let's not
forget um
that if this was a another political
movement let's say this was just a
pure you know capitalist political
movement or this was
a maga movement or something pro-trump
or just some
general you know 80s reaganites
something i'm pretty sure playstation
wouldn't be putting that
out for free so all of these
corporations have chosen a political
side
and and that is what i think is deeply
dangerous and by the way that is pretty
much what we're all voting on
that's what we're voting on in about a
week and a half because
it all comes down to this will
everything remain
politicized will corporations and
and radical political movements will
they
will they rule over us or or will we end
their power over us that seems to be
what's on the ballot
if you ask me speaking of the ballot uh
on thursday night we will be doing a
live stream
after the debate um i last time i did it
with whiskey
i think we're gonna go with tequila this
time i feel the need
for tequila this time so we're gonna do
that and i'll be back tomorrow with
another direct message and uh let's see
what else happens today at five in the
morning
or four in the morning the president
united states mention my name so
we'll we'll see how the rest of the day
goes oh and by the way
if you didn't see it jordan peterson
dropped a video yesterday
announcing his return it's going to it's
going to take a little time obviously
and he was a little cautious into
getting back in exactly but he lays out
a little bit about where he's been and
what's going on and what his plans are
and it was just it was just great to see
the guy's face
and uh you know pretty good to talk
about timing right like getting back in
the game like 10 days before the
election it's something else so check
that out on his channel
and i'll see you guys later
you